segundo día de camino con 15 kilómetros
por recorrer y la meta de llegar a eeuu
una nueva caravana de miles de migrantes
avanza por el estado de chiapas al sur
del país bajo estricta vigilancia de
agentes de migración y guardia nacional
hasta la ciudad de mexico lograr llegar
hasta ahí y hacerlo hacer documentación
allá porque aquí en tapachula en
tapachula no se puede no lo dejan a uno
demasiados días muchos emigrantes y no
nos dejan avanzar a 11 se queda sin
comer se lo que hace un trabajo después
de permanecer más de un año en chiapas
los migrantes en su mayoría de países
centroamericanos y de haití salieron
como respuesta a la política de
contención que el gobierno mexicano
desplegó en la ciudad de tapachula
frontera con guatemala vamos con río
adelante todo el tiempo
un cambio que va guiando a nosotros
adelante si la idea de llegar a eeuu
no me importa caminar ni bien y 2050 en
el 100 y 1000 km esta caravana se puso
en marcha luego de que los primeros días
de septiembre las autoridades mexicanas
frustran en el avance de cuatro
caravanas de migrantes que partieron
precisamente desde tapachula
la región vive una ola migratoria sin
precedentes desde el comienzo de este
año tan sólo entre enero y agosto se ha
detectado un flujo de hasta 147 mil
indocumentados en mexico el triple el
2020 una tragedia con el mundo como
testigo